[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire pour débattre discuter et
échanger sur les sujets d'actualité
alors des français demandeurs de
produits locaux jusque dans les rayons
de la grande distribution
c'est l'enseignement tiré du premier
confinement que nous avons connue entre
mars et mai 2020 alors que le salon de
l'agriculture aurait dû débuter le
week-end prochain et que les
négociations commerciales annuelles des
prix de l'agroalimentaire se termine
dans quelques jours on fait le point
dans les yvelines avec nos trois invités
bertrand de créer bonsoir vous êtes
associé eu et responsable national d'un
groupe de travail le meilleur du local
guillaume caffin bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes co fondateur des deux gourmands une
biscuiterie a créé pierre et au livret
couprie bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
céréaliers à montfort l'amaury alors le
1er mars prochain les négociations entre
la grande distribution et les
fournisseurs doivent aboutir souvent
c'est un moment de tension certains
producteurs reprochent à la grande
distribution des pressions pour baisser
les prix bertrand de créer la politique
des magasins us et plus de 1000
partenariat entre les magasins et des
producteurs et des entreprises
françaises c'est bien ça nous un axe
fondamental des mouvements
[Musique]
les choses ne se font pas en un an ces
longues et nous avons créé avec 1000
anticipée à un groupe de travail c'est
le meilleur du local comme vous l'avez
dit donc la mission est d'aller au
devant des agriculteurs des pme locales
innovantes autour de nous serait à
l'astuce c'est alors un chef
d'entreprise est inscrit dans son
territoire
nous sommes des indépendants est très
sensible à tout ce qui se passe votre
territoire
nous avons dans nos magasins nous on
sait vers les agriculteurs et les
paysans à produire et l'histoire oz
d'agir ensemble en meublé possible et
justement lhjmq a fait un bond on trouve
aux produits au sein de votre atelier
bien sûr mais aussi dans de nombreux
points de vente et certains dans la
grande distribution
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous ce
système de distribution notamment
peut-être pour votre chiffre d'affaires
bah écoutez ça représente aujourd'hui la
grande distribution
près de 35 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
donc on ne pourrait pas s'en passer
mais notre stratégie globalement et de
diversifier au maximum notre
distribution en or concrètement on a pu
développer une une boutique sur place
dans notre ferme a créé pierre par
exemple on travaille très bien travaillé
bien avec le réseau rh est connaît les
circonstances
aujourd'hui les hfc restauration hors
foyer
on vend aussi un peu sur internet bref
notre stratégie à nouveau minimisé les
risques a été de diversifier au maximum
la distribution monsieur et il se trouve
que parce que gérant allez-y je vous en
prie c'est moi qui vous ai coupé court
monsieur de créer nous travaillons
ensemble
puisqu'on est distribué
dans le magasin super u de santenay et
il se trouve que on a toujours été bien
les communautés tout à fait entendu par
l'ancien qu'il représente
cela dit donc les négociations cette
année avec système u se sont bien
déroulées avec d'autres jeux on sait
s'adapter mais j'ai toujours moins en
tête cette diversification dont je vous
parle là c'est l'une des solutions à
face à ce problème qu'on ne peut pas
tous mettre en oeuvre parce que c'est
compliqué ça demande des investissements
ça manque d'entraînement d'une équipe
voilà oui justement ce vous le disais
c'est pas vous avez pas les mêmes
relations avec tout votre distributeur
dans les médias nationaux on a vu des
producteurs qui indiquait qu'il recevait
des pressions de la part de la grande
distribution pour faire baisser les prix
notamment
vous avez connu cette situation était
pour la question était pour monsieur k
fin est ce que vous avez connu quelques
pressions d'autres distributeurs pour
faire baisser les prix
alors on est effectivement dans un
rapport de force qui est déséquilibré
sur le sujet prix on ne peut rien faire
on peut pas rivaliser donc là aussi en
fait une
la solution c'est de proposer le
meilleur produit qui soit venu notre
thématique chez des deux gourmands
c'est le local et la qualité et c'est en
cela on va se différencier énormément
sur notre marché et je pense que c'est
pour cela aussi que les distributeurs
nous retiennent il peut y avoir une
forme de conscience
à cet égard maintenant sur le sujet prix
évidemment quand on a quand on présente
des eaux ce qui est des hausses de prix
ce qui était le cas l'an dernier
c'est difficile à faire passer mais nous
y sommes arrivés
parce que ce que je vous expliquais le
sujet de la qualité de nos produits et
leurs dimensions locales ont su les
séduire j'imagine bien que ce n'est pas
le cas
pour tout le monde je sais puisque
journée dans une ferme agricole la ferme
de mes parents qui sont eux-mêmes
cultivateurs je sais au combien les
rapports peuvent être compliquées avec
avec des agriculteurs je pense que
monsieur compris va pouvoir il expliqué
voilà ce rapport de force il est
difficile pour moi la solution c'est une
réglementation enfin des règles un suivi
c'est aussi peut-être un peu plus de
protectionnisme privilégier les produits
français expliquait que la france c'est
des produits de qualité d'abord et enfin
c'est un travail qui sont au niveau du
consommateur à savoir le consommateur
doit avoir en tête et aussi les moyens
qu un produit français va ça vaut ça
vaut plus cher
voilà encore faut-il qu'ils se le permet
oui mais couperait justement en ce
moment on parle beaucoup de la loi et
galim sont les états généraux de
l'alimentation pour l' équilibre des
relations commerciales dans le secteur
agricole
emmanuel macron ces randos s'est rendue
en côte d'or pour rassurer les
agriculteurs vous vous êtes céréaliers
donc soumis aussi aux marchés
internationaux
qu'est ce que ça implique pour vous
quelles sont vos relations aussi avec
les autres strates de la distribution
alors maintenant que polyculteur je suis
loin de la démarche et de la grande
distribution mais discuter là en
l'émission avec un producteur guff un
producteur de pommes de terre ainsi
qu'un producteur de l'aide pour le
compte n'y est pas dans cette fois et
gagner mais effectivement ce que disait
guillaume de force qui est difficile il
ya des enseignes qui jouent le jeu et
surtout la loi et gagne c'est vraiment
quelque chose
enfin c'est une grande loi à être plein
de choses dedans on a beaucoup parlé il
ya un an en septembre 2019 des zones de
l'entraînement libre à ça c'est dans la
loi légalise les fameuses
néonicotinoïdes et leur arrêt c'est
pareil c'est dans la loi et galim donc
voilà on nous producteurs voilà il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses dans nos
vallées galim et le
la grande espérance était pour ceux qui
vendent en direct des fruits et légumes
grande distribution c'était d'avoir un
meilleur prix la loi égalité et être
lancée c'est quasiment impossible
c'était une très bonne attention tenir
compte du coût de revient de la
production de l'agriculteur mais comme
on est soumis aux produits de la pomme
de terre ou des salades à marcher
qu'international quand les salades et
des pays frontaliers de la france sont
un peu moins cher
il ya beau y avoir la loi et galim ça ne
ne protège pas le prix des producteurs
français justement bertrand degré de ce
côté là on parle de qualité il faut
aussi quand c'est du local souvent le
prix est un peu plus élevé est-ce qu'il
ya aussi une sensibilisation à faire
auprès du consommateur
alors vous savez j'aime verdissement de
mes deux lotos le docteur guillaume à a
dit deux choses trois choses très
importantes
il appelle qualité de local et est
pourquoi je crois qu'il ya une vraie
éducation et 50 sociétés de l'ue
consommateurs l'accepté ou pas je trouve
qu'on peut vendre que cher pour une
bonne une juste rémunération des
entrepreneurs agriculteurs pourvu qu'on
produise des produits d'une qualité et
avec un pinot carbone réduite s'ils sont
ils sont locaux et à côté comme en ce
compris dit qu'il est loin de la grande
distribution poussette n'est pas si loin
tous les deux parce que vous voyez
ward est peut-être votre blé aux grands
moulins versailles
non oui je le vois une coopérative qui
va le rendre côté là j'ai un accord
particulier que les grandes versailles
j'ai une reprise locales et tout le pain
que nous faisons au super u de fontenay
il est fait avec la faille de versailles
et après ce qu'il me dise le blairer
coque et dans les 100 km autour
donc c'est quelque part c'est votre blé
qui doit intervenir dans notre pas et ça
vous avez vous blé de loi lannoy ne fait
pas tout ce sont les hommes et la bonne
volonté des hommes moi qui pense que qui
ont pour en témoigner
jamais je puisse parler du prix ou
d'habitation prix sur ses produits
on a parlé qualité j'ai vu voir dans son
atelier on a parlé du cal
on y parlait justement consommateurs et
et le prix des produits
dix membres le prix sont capables de
payer nos consommateurs effectivement
demain ça n'a pas de sens d'avoir un
truc qu'ils en pas un échec pour tout le
monde mais nos gosses poserait jeu en
train de monter un gain de vos confrères
monsieur couprie un projet qui va voir
le jour dans dans plusieurs mois c'est
très lourd en plaine de versailles
justement où on a fait le pari tous les
deux les agriculteurs des mois le mas
tributaire de pouvoir faire produits et
le raisonner sur en ultra locales et on
aura peut-être des produits plus chers
que chez eux jusque produire la planète
mais c'est un vrai enjeu un vrai pari
pour nous et on est prêt à s'engager la
vue aux cônes aux consommateurs en
mettra en avant ses points durs les
mettra on les proposera et ont réussi ce
pari
j'espère que justement parce que dans
l'équation il faut des producteurs
distributeurs et des consommateurs
et effectivement la volonté déjà quand
il est affirmé qu'elle est mise en
oeuvre le premier plan mais il fait
aussi l'écho il est bon d'en donc on va
tout faire pour ça vous parlez des
produits locaux au sein de la grande
distribution selon une étude de
l'observatoire leclerc et ipsos qui a
été réalisé en à la fin du mois d'avril
2020 les français se sont aussi tournés
davantage pas vers les produits
d'origine hexagonale c'est une volonté
qui a aussi poussé les grands
distributeurs à se fondant
principalement auprès des producteurs
français
on écoute quelques précisions de michel
edouard leclerc le
président directeur général du groupe du
même nom il était au micro dé l'honore
sinoquet
pendant la période de confinement vous
savez il n'y a pas de produits importés
donc déjà eu
ça a été un débouché accru pour la
production nationale française faux ce
qui est en même temps cette la crise des
transports la difficulté de traverser la
france fait que le local a été une
redécouverte pour à la fois les
distributeurs et la distribution a été
une redécouverte pour des producteurs
qui ne pensaient pas la grande
distribution capable de vendre leurs
produits
et ici à rambouillet comme un peu
partout en france les gains de local de
produits locaux ont pris une grande
extension et surtout il ya eu des
contrats qui ont été signés qui
permettent finalement d'espérer dans le
long terme que cette relation perdure
[Musique]
les modèles de distribution ne se
ressemblent pas les centres leclerc sont
des indépendants comme système u comme
intermarché et donc ils sont
complètement libres de n'offrir s'ils
veulent que du local bien évidemment il
faut offrir ce qui est demandé par le
consommateur qui est lui-même influencé
par la publicité par ses propres besoins
les enjeux de la relocalisation c'est de
donner une explication aussi au
consommateur sur la qualité des produits
sur le fait que derrière la chaque
produit il ya de l'emploi derrière il ya
de l'emploi au pays
c'est une possibilité pour les
agriculteurs aussi pour les producteurs
de valoriser leur production de ne pas
tomber dans la banalisation et après
tout qu'un produit ce soit labellisé
charte rambouillet c'est une valeur
ajoutée qui donne droit à une
rémunération supplémentaire et nous
avons lu voulu voir si les saint
quentinois été attentifs aux produits
locaux à ce qui mettait dans leur
assiette assiette et c'est justin ghazi
patrick jacques de dixmude qui ont été
les voir je préfère ça fait travailler
petits producteurs tout ça et c'est tout
à fait normal
j'ai trop de d'espagne il faut faire
travailler les gens qui sont près de
chez nous et pas forcément qu'ils soient
des gens qui soient un des milliers de
kilomètres gène de la campagne c'est
très important
on mange mieux déjà même si le rapport
qualité-prix n'y est pas on mange bien
quand tout va bien généralement les
marchandises et tout circule très
facilement mais en ce moment difficile
je pense oui
c'est par solidarité ont du coup plus on
l'a entendu les saint quentinois
notamment veulent manger local ça peut
surprendre dans le sens où il ya aussi
un aghrib aching depuis quelques années
vous avez vous même avec jérôme regnault
et fané dur en bouclant c'est une
hotline pour rassurer les consommateurs
c'est la première étape finalement pour
pouvoir vendre à grande échelle
oui mais alors c'est de créer parler des
hommes
et voilà le producteur voilà une somme d
des familles qui sont qui sommes
attachés à notre terroir de production
et on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
un décalage entre ce que pensait le
consommateur de l'agriculture est ce que
nous ont dit veille et donc on a voulu
relouer en créant un numéro vert où les
consommateurs peuvent nous appeler pour
savoir comment produits l'agriculteur
lui même un capital sympathie qu
important mais l'agriculture ne l'a pas
forcément parce qu'elle est allée mal
expliqué donc nous on est prêt à relever
les défis à produire du local du
différentes qualités qui correspondent
aux différentes gammes qui sont vendus
en gms
il faut que la marche soit équitable
parce que ça c'est vraiment important
peut-être que par un système
d'étiquetage en disant voilà le produit
français il ya un coût social de
sécurité sociale qui est plus important
que les pays qui sont en périphérie de
la france et qui est meilleur encore
plus inquiets perrichon en périphériques
de l'europe voit la difficulté quand
même c'est quand même on est soumis pour
un grand nombre de choses au cours aux
cours mondiaux qui influent sur les prix
donc voilà il faut que arriver à ce que
tout le monde puisse jouer le jeu je
pense qu'il faut faire un effort aussi
sur l'étiquetage
et la grande distribution n'augmente pas
ses marges sur le local et les produits
bureau que la marge soit mieux répartie
avec les producteurs justement
d'étiquetage guillaume caffin vos
matières premières viennent de toute
l'île de france
c'est aussi une marque de fabrique chez
vous ça a évolué depuis son lancement
sept autres traitera des aides en
réalité que d'être transparent déjà et
que de se sélectionner en priorité des
produits qui viennent d'île de france
autour de chez nous donc voilà c'est
fondamental pour nous pour d'autres ça
n'est pas il ya des choses qui sont
mises en place par exemple au niveau
régional avec la marque produit en ile
de france
monsieur de craie disait qu'il faut
s'inscrire en fait dans le ton loin dans
le temps long on est on est on est on
est au début de quelque chose et
l'impression que seiko d'ailleurs votre
reportage le montre on se rend compte
que les sondés les interviewés
particulier veulent des produits locaux
et michel edouard leclerc explique que
ça a été un succès lorsqu'on lui
lorsqu'on l'a imposée en magasin voilà
il ya des idées qui se trame c'est à
dire que les gens en veulent et les gens
sont les gens l'achètent de l'oca donc
comme disait monsieur compris tant qu'on
sera sur des cours internationaux sur
les matières premières j'entends les
céréales et autres ce sera toujours un
peu compliqué de rivaliser donc je peux
effectivement une éducation du
consommateur dire les français en raison
de nous soucier dalle en raison d'un
coût environnemental en raison d'un coût
d'une qualité exceptionnelle ont un coût
ont un prix plus cher
voilà mais les ij allez vous donner la
parole je vous en prie d'accord et ce
qu'avait imaginé en clair à une toute
petite chose c'est que lyon n'a pas
attendre vite pour ça notre travail
c'est une fin volonté que nous avant
d'aller de tendre la loi a cp mieux de
les aider et je m'assure que monsieur
compris il est temps de prendre plus de
marges des produits locaux on a deux
marques genève unige france mais
aujourd'hui la tendance à laquelle
vaincu les mots ne joue pas mal de
travail qu'on appelle chez nous pas de
la rose cependant on la crée entre
hommes
je suis depuis dix ans 10
tout tourne au nouvel entraîneur
français et vous verrez on n'a eu qu'un
seul message pendant 20 ans à la grande
distribution je vend moins cher que l'on
joue c'est un message qu'on a passée les
basques ont revendiqué cola parce qu'on
vend du coca cola parce qu'on voit le
degré si variait lille ces profils sont
utiles et nécessaires
mais aujourd'hui on veut vraiment être
acteurs reste localement associé de
laquelle on vit c'est de tendre la main
à tous cette belle production que nous
avons à ce que font ces hommes et femmes
français et ça il faut effectivement là
ça c'est la volonté
c'est ce qu'on va construire demandé de
construire il faut aussi d'ailleurs que
le consommateur mais je pense regarde
que moi qui prêts à le faire parce que
justement ces produits sont produits
localement donne de l'emploi localement
parce que ils sont qualitativement use
hâtivement souvent meilleur et bien nous
pourrons réussir ce pari
justement vous disiez tout à l'heure que
avec le groupe de travail
vous allez à la rencontre des
producteurs comment vous entrez en
contact avec eux est ce qu'à un moment
ils viennent vous voir eux mêmes vous
avez des équipes qui sillonnent des
territoires alors
mais comme je vous le dis on est souvent
logo vous donc déjà on a nos propres
antennes
on sait alors ils émettent le plus vide
nous a un peu aidés parce que beaucoup
de petites entreprises est tout proche
de nous et avait peur de nous la grande
distribution une telle image que vietze
petites tpe même papa pme tpe
on leur fait peur et il vendait comme et
guillaume très diversifiée en chr mais
quand le ch s'est écroulé ils ont eu de
gros soucis
et là ils sont venus nous voir mais par
des relais par des relais et ils ont
découvert que les fameux monstre qui
étaient les distributeurs bas pouvait
des hommes des coaches qui peut être
construire avec eux et j'ai un exemple
de pme dans laquelle je n'étais pas
c'est pas client j'ai découvert grâce
provident les prolongations plus je suis
son plus gros client parce qu'il tourne
vers nous parce qu'on va vers eux
alors après on a aussi des fichiers on
en travaillant comme l'aria qui nous met
en contact
justement avec des pmm salle il ya tout
à l'apprentissage à faire j'ai peur moi
je pars guillon pour en témoigner
jamais jamais et au grand jamais on leur
met de pression de ristournes d'accords
signés
on travaille avec eux il ya surtout des
hommes qui se rencontrent qui on vit
ensemble parce qu'on est des acteurs
locaux
la ferme de guillaume elle et elle est à
moins de 10 kilomètres de mon magasin
on est des acteurs locaux ensemble et on
fait en exclu une histoire on est loin
des chiffres et puis je dire si demain
les podiums se vendent pas on se posera
la question tous les deux est ce que
c'est on prie ses prochains d'avoir ma
marche qui la connaît puisqu'il vend les
produits en direct donc il sait ce que
je pense que ces produits
il me les ventes et en se posant la
question tous les deux on dira ensemble
car pourquoi ça serait ce que pour les
mal positionné pour parce qu'il est mal
ni pourquoi pourquoi ça ne sort pas et
s'il a écrit ensemble c'est pas un bras
de fer s'est pas justement il faut
sortir cette équation
des voitures est ce qu'on veut faire ses
débuts avec le meilleur de nos 4 s'il
arrivait à ce contact humain crivelli j
le look à la densité sont aussi parce
que quelque part sont aussi nos nos
clients à nous parce que quand tu es
quand ils sont autant créer de l'emploi
le gal mangou ont créé des clients
également et c'est ce qui fait qu'on a
une société plus équilibrée
il est compris justement puisque comme
vous en tant que ces ralliés il y à des
intermédiaires jusqu'à ce que le client
puisse goûter votre production vous
savez où partent vos cultures
alors elles partent au local au national
ou à l'international
donc ça ça va un peu partout et je
voulais rebondir sur le consommateur
aurait tu nous disais tout à l'heure on
est prêts on ne mange à créer dès que
comme guillaume a fait des biscuits fade
et des produits locaux
il faut aussi que le consommateur qui
est aussi notre voisin dans les champs
dans les villages ils acceptent le il
veut manger du poulet de plein air
après il faut qu'ils acceptent qui est
un bâtiment qui puisse ce compte qui
peut se construire en périphérie du
village pour élever des poules est en
plein air ça aussi la problématique
n'est prêt à relever les choses il faut
qu'on ait pas trop de contrainte parce
que pour pouvoir mener ses projets il
faut aussi que voilà il ya une tonne de
pétitions ou de pressions contre ces
nouvelles formes d'agriculture qui
demande de construire des serres des
bâtiments pour pouvoir localement quand
on l'a on a besoin que consommateurs ils
jouent le jeu de payer un petit peu plus
cher et d'accepter d'avoir à côté de
chez lui un producteur et y aura une
petite nuisances visuelles olfactives
éventuellement et donc voilà on a besoin
de recréer ce lien avec le avec nos
voisins
c'est hyper important parce qu'on
souffre de ce manque de reconnaissance
et gain facile quand on the go allez-y
pour appuyer monsieur monsieur couprie
là-dessus savait que le projet je vous
parlais que je peux pas dévoiler
entièrement aujourd'hui kate un accord
avec un agriculteur qui est pas qui est
un confrère de monsieur couprie
ça fait un an et demi contre cette idée
un an et demi et on n'a pas pu planter
la première carottes
pourquoi parce qu'on en parle de
versailles conques ont subi alors
justement vous parlez de serre par les
choses comme ça parce qu'on veut faire
on veut pas vous mettre des artificiers
ont vu des choses d'actu réseau les on
peut mettre quand même des fins
l'agriculteur peut mettre des barrières
mais c'est compliqué il ya fallait faire
des tic hydrique et il a fallu faire
plein de choses on n'a pas pu alors que
l'idée on a la volonté ont été ceux qui
veut vendre
on a un à un à quelqu'un qu'il faut
produire mais quelque part mon dieu que
c'est dur et je veux jouer oui mon dieu
que c'est du lourd
ils en font la volonté alors le temps
file à très très vite je vais poser une
dernière question à monsieur caffin ce
souvent on parle de grande distribution
a en quelques secondes voire six si on
peut répondre à cette question est ce
que ça veut dire grandes productions
aussi où vous vous entendez qu'il ya
distributeurs sur une quantité que vous
êtes à même de proposer non on peut être
en grande distribution et produire peu
et surtout produire produire bien c'est
l'exemple de notre histoire puisque on a
une distribution en local uniquement et
on a comme règle c'est là c'est
important toujours une histoire d'hommes
tant que et c'est notre volonté avec mon
associé louis temps qu'on décidera de
toujours respecter nos valeurs et de
toujours respecter nos produits on sera
sur cette même ligne de conduite et vous
produira du bord et du local voilà on va
terminer sur ces quelques mots parce que
le temps est passé bien trop vite le 7-8
société maintenant terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis merci à tous les trois
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
vous pouvez revoir l'émission en replay
sur notre site internet où notre
application mobile
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau sujet d'actualité
[Musique]